it takes people to in Haiti at the same
time to make any sort of change to what
they're doing of course you want to have
a good reception but you don't make a
movie by committee last tape was really
good we had that little moment didn't
we've seen other actors who stand and
somebody shouts action and they're just
going I don't know what to do I've never
particularly been asked to do
transformations but you know you just go
you just get it in your head then you
just go I need to I'm very my own
picking what I choose I don't have any
strategy I don't have any plans and then
a horrible moment when you see a
director guy God you know looking at you
like ah Jesus Christ he's an English
actor known for going to great lengths
to portray characters in his films he
first caught the attention of the public
eye when he was 13 and he was cast in
the starring role of Empire of the Sun
he went on to receive greater
recognition and commercial success with
his role as Bruce Wayne / Batman he's
Christian Bale and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success he's the reason
that you get out of bed to go act every
when you do because when is good it's
really good than when it's not and hate
it you know but when it's good it's it's
a love-hate thing and it's a love/hate
thing for me because of coming from a
place where it was actually a
responsibility a young age because you
know for my family was just such an
unfathomable amount of sudden cash that
you could get for doing it that I went
yeah well even I don't really feel like
doing it I can't really live with myself
for not because it helps my family so
much you know and so I felt
responsibility to do that
so I come at it from a slightly
different point of view you know it
wasn't something that I said I went
through school going oh you know I'd
like to become an actor or we are love
films oh that's what I'm gonna try to do
it was something that happened at an
early age and then I went I can't
out of this because it's really helpful
to my family you know and so yeah and I
must do it so that's why I've got this
slight love/hate thing with it but I
actually think the love-hate is quite a
healthy thing to have if all you do is
love film if we do is love acting you're
just going to imitate what you love
right it takes people to hate it at the
same time to make any sort change to
what they're doing you know and to me
that's when you know it becomes
interesting fails now been on our screen
since he was a little boy since
Spielberg's Empire of the Sun yeah I
loved the experience of doing it even I
was kind of strange you know I was 12
years old and I was off in these
countries by myself and then the
armature so I loved but then you get all
the press you have to do afterwards and
that kind of did my head in a little bit
and made me go out forget it it's like
for me then and still now you always
yeah yeah no but that's alright the
reason I love being an actor is because
I'm not playing myself it's the only
thing I know how to do as well there is
that too
I left school really early and I never
paid attention anyways this is not a
career of last resort it's the only
choice there is nothing else I'm not
good at anything else when it comes to
pleasing people listen of course you
want to have a good reception but you
don't make a movie by committee and so I
have to make a movie that I would want
to see and I have to create a character
that I am interested in and that's it I
put my head down and I focus on that and
I don't really pay attention to what
people may be requesting because I
believe that if we have enough
conviction and what we're doing that
people will believe it as well my belief
is that techniques should change for
every single film that you make that you
can have you can get into ruts that can
be bad ruts where nothing's working
but equally when everything's working
that's a rut as well and you have to get
out of it you have to just abandon it
because it starts to become phony if you
go in will this work for us before and
it
be from film to film er can be from take
to take last take was really good we had
that little moment didn't we you said
that and I went rude and you were and it
was great everyone went uh so let's do
that again he'll never be the same so
you actually have to try to make sure no
ignore that blow it apart and do
something totally different you know
hopefully they got that on camera that's
that's the choice they have now do
something completely different and a
similar thing we're going from one film
to the next at you working with the same
director don't fall back on your old
tricks from the old film that was a
different film different tricks were
needed you know go the new tricks don't
be a one-trick pony you see you do very
strong characters and pretty much
everything you're very strong decisions
do you make those decisions before you
start and then kind of come to the set
with what you're going to do and then
adjust in small ways are you what the
way I always approach it is this that I
like to have my own ideas completely
worked out so that if a director I come
to find his working method is that he
doesn't want to talk to me mm-hmm
that I'm not at a loss there's nothing
worse I've seen other actors who stand
in somebody shouts action and they just
go in I don't know what to do I need
they they need somebody to come and tell
them what to do I never look at a
director or somebody who tells me what
to do I look at it as someone who we
work together in something and therefore
I need to be responsible too so I have
to bring something to the table and say
I will do it this way if you never said
if you keep silent this is how I'll do
it and I'll give a few different
versions but it would be it wouldn't
matter if they said nothing I've never
particularly been asked to do
transformations but you know you just go
you just get it in your head then you
just go I need to that's that's what I
need to do I don't know how to play that
part without looking that way I always
talk with the director about it it's
just that they don't necessarily
understand quite to what lengths I might
be talking about there's no point in
doing something if you're not going to
do it
absolutely you know and do it to the
hill and and so yeah did they come a
point when I suddenly started to get
more satisfaction out of it and
realizing there was something that even
though I can't quite bring myself to say
something of worth to it that I can say
something worth me doing it for and if
I'm going to do it if I'm going to take
the time to do it
then I want to do it in as much of an
immersive way as possible because you
know you just come to learn in life that
the things that you really get a kick
out of are the things that you just
can't deny they're the things that when
you're doing them you can think of
nothing else but what you're doing you
know cut up my whole arm and wrist I got
metal plates here and here and screws
all up and down my arm through riding
motorcycles not on the streets but on
racetracks and that was something which
I realized was was very much when acting
is good why I like it because when
you're riding a motorcycle to the hilt
knowing the danger involved you have to
be absolutely focused on what you're
doing you can't allow anything else in
and there is such a thrill to doing that
you know that's why it's so hypnotic and
just mesmerizing I just love it and I
realized that the best times I feel a
similar thing with acting and it doesn't
happen that often because it's a team
thing you know on a motorcycle it's just
you and it going this is a team thing
and you require the environment to be
created in which you can do that but the
when that does happen that's what I love
about it yeah it was in talking with
Adam and hearing just you know man this
guy was so obsessed with this with this
subject and um you know I want to work
with people who are obsessed with what
they're doing you know I don't want to
work with anyone who's just sort of you
know phoning it in and loose all right I
could do it or do something else I want
somebody's got
to do this film I gonna do this films
that's very attractive you wanna meet
you run your I am I'm brain my own
picking what I choose I don't have any
strategy I have any plans I don't have
any particular kind of film that I can
articulate that I like I just I just
look at you know each day very up-close
what's in front of me do I like it does
it stick with me could I work on it for
a few months that's it the slightest
amount of control that I have is what
happens on the actual set we sometimes
get really great scenes that come no but
that happens you know so what do you do
you say to yourself all right well let's
get the satisfaction out of actually
making it that's the only way it's the
only way to get any satisfaction from
the rest of it is all gravy but it must
be always be a great moment when you see
the light and director's eyes seeing
something they didn't expect when you're
on that sir oh that's great oh of course
yeah yeah when they come I and I didn't
notice that and then a horrible moment
when you see a director guy God you know
looking at you like oh Jesus Christ
or actually saying that you know Jesus
Christ what was that you know walking
past you and just going I said what are
you go was that like what you know I
didn't explain why if you're swearing at
me you know but that's why I enjoy I
enjoy that I enjoy the all the different
relationship so you have it sounds like
it's about as good as it can get right
now something finding interesting things
and doing the work the way you need to
do it and yeah but you know pride comes
before a fold isn't it you know I mean
you get you you never know you know I
mean that that's what I do enjoy you
just really never know you and then and
and so often the films that people think
you should do and are the right moves
and seem to be great it's too good to be
true for a reason and you end up going
yes
okay that's it you know and so often
what I've found in my own career if you
wanna call it that is it's the films
where people go there's a big chance
that this is going to go south and I
tend to go that's what I want to do that
and they tend to be the ones that either
really and go south or Wow that that
really surprised everybody it came out
with something you know very different
so ya know you can never be too sure at
all you know another thing I think I
think that would be you know being too
sure is complacency isn't it and you're
gonna die you're gonna die quickly from
from complacency thank you so much for
watching I made this video because dil z
GFX asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur you want me to profile next
leave in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know
which of Christian Bale's top 10 rules
hit you the hardest and why leave it in
the comments I will join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon